this is part one of a conversation with
the inimitable david walpert you'll want
to watch this one all the way until the
end to understand the concepts which
will be referenced in part two where we
take questions from you as well as
hearing questions from kevin knuth anil
seth carl fristen and chris langan all
posed to david wallpart check the
description for the link to part two
david walpart is a mathematician a
physicist and a computer scientist he's
also the pioneer of three limiting
theorems including the no free lunch
theorem which as astounding as the no
free launch theorem is is actually the
least monumental of the three that
statement alone is a testament to how
seminal david's work is today we talk
about free will and what the limiting
theorems have to say about the
restrictions on attaining scientific
knowledge in general as usual click on
the timestamps in the description if
you'd like to skip this intro this
episode much like most of the podcasts
on the toe channel is extremely
technical but don't be dismayed stick
with it even if you don't understand it
as repeat viewings are what allow you to
in john wheeler's words get wet the
whole point is simply to get wet rather
than to drink from the fire holes this
episode will serve as an introduction to
david walpert's ideas and then later
we'll have a deep dive into the
intricacies of david walpart's theorems
for a part two this means you should
write down your questions write down all
your questions either privately in some
document or publicly let's say in the
youtube comment section especially
because i'll be calling from there since
when you write it may spur questions in
others or it may even answer a question
that someone else had limiting theorems
and no go theorems which can be used
interchangeably you'll hear this
terminology plenty are epochal and
particularly relevant to the subject of
theories of everything since many people
attempt to formulate their own theory of
everything and contravene certain bounds
without realizing that they're
overstepping certain limitations for
example if one believes that every
well-founded mathematical statement can
be either proved or disproved then one
is
violating girdle without knowing it
girdles incompleteness theorem there's
nothing wrong with violating per se it's
just that one should know when they're
violating and what the implications of
that violation are so for example
perhaps it implies that you can create a
perpetual motion machine or that you
have a method of trivially predicting
the outcome of some chaotic
configuration in short understanding no
go theorems allow you to understand what
loopholes exist and thus gives you an
intricate understanding of the inner
workings of reality my name is kirchey
mungle i'm a torontonian filmmaker with
a background in mathematical physics
dedicated to the explication of the
variegated terrain of theories of
everything from a theoretical physics
perspective but as well as delineating
the possible connection consciousness
has to the fundamental laws of nature
if those laws exist at all and are
knowable to us if you enjoy witnessing
and engaging with others on the topic of
psychology consciousness physics etc
then check the description for a link to
the theories of everything discord as
well as subreddit there's also a link to
the patreon that is
patreon.com if you'd like to contribute
as the patrons and the sponsors are the
only reasons that i can do podcasts with
this level of quality and depth
as now this is what i do full-time
thanks to their support with regard to
sponsors there are two the first sponsor
is brilliant during the break i decided
to brush up on some fundamentals in
physics so i committed myself to
learning one lesson per day on brilliant
some point soon i'd like to speak to
chiara marletto on constructor theory
which is predicated heavily in
information theory so i took a course on
random variable distributions and
knowledge and uncertainty despite
previously knowing the formula for
entropy as it's hammered into you as an
undergrad it was extremely edifying to
see a different explanation of the
formula for entropy that doesn't seem
like one that's been handed down
arbitrarily from god
instead after taking the course it's
easy to see why the formula for entropy
is the way that it is and how it's an
extremely natural choice there are
plenty of courses including ones on
group theory which is what's being
referenced when you hear that the
standard model has in it u1 cross su-2
cross su-3
those are technically called league
groups visit brilliant.org
toe t-o-e to get 20 off your annual
subscription
i recommend that you don't stop before
four lessons and i think you'll be
greatly surprised at the ease at which
you can now comprehend subjects that you
previously had a difficult time grocking
at least i know i did the second sponsor
is algo algo is an end-to-end supply
chain optimization software company with
software that helps business users
optimize sales and operations planning
to avoid stockouts reduce returns and
inventory write-downs while reducing
inventory investment it's a supply chain
ai that drives smart roi headed by amjad
hussein who himself has a podcast on
artificial intelligence and
consciousness and business growth if you
like this podcast the toe podcast and
want to support then visit omjad's
podcast link is in the description as
subscribing to amjad's channel
indirectly supports the toe channel
thank you and enjoy
i've always been interested in theories
of everything as i think any physicist
any theoretical physicist should be
well there that's a controversial
statement but at least if you're naive
you should be interested in that and
then maybe later you realize okay there
are limitations and so on now those
limitations is where our conversation
comes in i get emailed probably much
like yourself many theories from people
maybe you don't get emailed that but
either way i get email plenty of
theories and they violate some limiting
theorem or no go theorem and they don't
realize that they're doing this so i
thought you know what how about
while i'm on this journey to investigate
the different theories of everything how
about we educate people on the different
limiting theorems that exist now you
have three which is extremely rare most
people would kill for one and in the
wall so that's why i'm extremely
interested in speaking with you and
we're just going to talk about those
limiting theorems and what the
implications are
okay i'll do my best i thought i'd break
this down into three stages
one for each of the limiting theorems
now you have three as we've talked about
off air the no free lunch theorem which
we're going to abbreviate as nfl and
then the unreality of laplace's demon
slash limits on science that's under the
umbrella of i'm unsure what you call the
theorem but i as far as i call it the
limits on inferences so limits on
inferences a second and the noisy
deductive
reasoning which you've
told me that it flourishes the
foundations of mathematics but i'm
unfamiliar with that
theorem so i'll be i'm extremely excited
to hear about that
okay so um
no free lunch there's actually several
different flavors of the no free lunch
theorems
there's the ones that have to do with
induction
which can be viewed as a
formalization of david hume's
informal idea
um and which have
lots of implications for machine
learning and so on so forth then there's
also the versions that have to do with
um optimization and search
um
inference devices there's actually a
whole bunch of impossibility results
um the uh
monotheism theorems and the days and
theorems and so on those are two of them
and they're up front
the noisy deductive reasoning
that's i wouldn't refer to that as
impossibility or no go theorems that's
very much work in progress um that's
probably
it's on the front most burner of all
those um
separate projects
what is
what me and my collaborator david kinney
are doing there is instead
trying to understand what the
implications would be if we just
pursued the time-honored tradition now
in mathematics
of weakening one of its foundation
stones
let the edifice
then crumble and relax into a bit a
somewhat different shape than we had
known before
and try to say some things about that
particular shape
so it's not so much a no-go theorem you
will not be able to
invoke it when you get one of your email
correspondence and say oh this violates
the blah blah
it's instead much more of a project that
in a certain senses
even
undermining the legitimacy of the others
and that it's saying
it's taking seriously
the fact that in mathematical deduction
you are never it isn't does not seem to
be possible and so let's not take it as
an axiom rather than try to prove it or
not that you're ever actually a hundred
percent sure that every step in your
proof is
correct and that's obviously true when
people first come up with say a
suggested solution to the poncare
conjecture or something like that
or when andy wiles came up with
his proofs that among other things
established from us last theorem
um it was very very clear at the time
that there was a non-zero probability
that there was a mistake somewhere that
it was wrong
mathematicians tend
to um
treat these results as though they
almost for lack of a better way to
undergo a phase transition that after
people have gone over them enough
that yeah now we're sure of them and
we're going to treat them as 100 percent
i'm ironclad
holy writ
what important fact of course that's
never what happens is rather the set of
people are always it's a
sarcastic process by which you come to
greater and greater confidence in the
results may i interject
please please please sure do that
as much as you possibly can otherwise i
have a tendency to open loop yeah i'd
i'd like to make this i'd like to make
this clear for the audience generally
when a mathematician proves something
you don't go through
what you may learn in a logic course
which is you state the axioms then you
have some rules of inference like modus
ponens and then you go step one is a
step two step three step four step five
that's actually extremely tedious even
to prove the most simple theorems now
this can be done on a computer
but well this can be done on a computer
so i don't think
professor you're talking about that
actually even then because this is for
example uh the proofs of the four color
map theorem which is the first one that
was done on a
computer it's actually a somewhat
controversial um issue in practicing
mathematics as well as philosophy of
mathematics
is
first of all is it a proof if human
beings can't understand it but even more
to the point you now have to validate
the actual code the program that's being
used and that can never be done to a
hundred percent
so you can't ever quite i don't think
there's actually anybody has tried to
formally have a no-go theorem that
proves this
um which is an interesting idea but as a
matter of practice it there's always
some place that you need to simply say
well it's been vetted it's good enough
let's run with it and not scrutinize us
anymore
your operating system um computer
programs cosmic ray can hit a transistor
and it can make a fluctuation so you
think that's validated by computer
even then you're not completely
100 sure now what do mathematicians say
in response to what you're saying
because it's as if you're undermining
the entire validity of their existence
oh um well they say that very very
quickly you get to the the situation
where the probability that it's um
actually mistaken
it get the more it gets scrutinized the
lower that probability becomes
formally though because informally you
can say that can you say well we believe
with a
99.58 certainty in fermat's last
theorem's proof for example they never
actually do that this is all a matter of
heuristics the sociology of the field
um the natural so one of the ways of
viewing the motivation for the noisy
deductive reasoning stuff
is that you can imagine trying to
actually formalize that say there is a
stochastic process
um you can imagine just where we are
what's called iid so just independent
identically distributed
i'm doing samples of whether
so you can imagine a very very simple
model
where here is a hypothesis
a proposed theorem
and that you are many times
independently testing with a simple bit
flip
um is this actually true or not
and if you keep getting those flips that
um keep coming up saying true true true
true and they're all independent
then according to many things like
bayesian reasoning and so on and so
forth it depends upon what are called
your prior probabilities
what's called your posterior probability
that actually is true given the data
that it's been tested now a thousand
times now a hundred thousand times now a
million times
the probability that's wrong as the
number of tests the number of different
people who have checked it over
keeps growing
that probability of error shrinks as the
number of checks grows
it's actually you can make a very very
simple model where it's formally
identical to the proposition that the
sun will rise tomorrow
you personally um kurt have seen the sun
rise i don't know a couple of thousand
times
if we may be um squinting our definition
of what it means for you personally to
see it rise
we could allow you to build to pull upon
social media or just general media and
so on and say it's even tens of
thousands
so something called laplace's law of
succession this goes back to simone
laplace
where he uses very very simple bayesian
reasoning um he was actually the first
person to
really use bayesian reasoning beys
didn't really use it essentially
um so laplace used it to get to estimate
trajectories of plants or whatnot but in
any case there's something called
laplace's law of succession
which says that if you have seen it um
rise
a thousand times and you've never seen
it fail to rise
then under a very reasonable choice for
what's called the prior probability you
would expect you would assign the
expected chance of it rising tomorrow
is a thousand and one divided by a
thousand and two
but that's not the same thing as one
so you can build a very very simple um a
model of what mathematicians are doing
which is that every time a new
mathematician takes a new look at the
proposed proof
that it's just like i'm having the sun
do another test of whether the sun's
rising
and just like every time you see the sun
rise from one day to the next you get
more and more confident that yep the sun
will also rise tomorrow
mathematicians every time they do a new
um
test of having somebody scrutinize it
and coming up and saying yep looks
legitimate to me you can say there's a
greater probability that the next
mathematician will come to that same
conclusion
but in both cases
you'll never actually
achieve
a notion
anything like whether you can even
define it as saying it is true 100
and so you can build simple mathematic
models of the mathematical process along
those lines and doing that you can
actually justify some common mathematics
heuristics
mathematical reason is for example if
you
um are
still in the stage where you're trying
to ascertain whether you think a
proposition a proposed theorem is true
if
as a mathematician or the theoretician
in any field
if there are what you might view as
multiple independent lines of reasoning
all of which say that that proposition
is true
versus there only being one
when there's multiple independent ones
you are going to assign higher
probability to being true then and not
being true
that's as a matter of
social practice humans do that
and by using this model of mathematical
reasoning you can actually say guess
what that's actually formally
justifiable
using some of the rules of bayesian
reasoning
so one thing one can do
is take this approach to what
mathematicians actually do
and actually
establish that some of the heuristics
that mathematicians engage in are
actually legitimate
but where things become much more
interesting to me at least personally
is if you say along the spirit that well
that's weak in the parallel line
postulate and look guess what comes out
non-euclidean geometry in all of its
riches
let's weaken the postulate the continuum
hypothesis and guess what what comes up
is all different kinds of mathematical
logics and so on and so forth
we can say let's weaken the hypothesis
that mathematics itself is in some sense
external to humans
the humans are discovering it and that
it mathematics
is ironclad with every step being
following from a previous step
in a deterministic manner instead let's
weaken that and assume that it's not
just mathematicians
who are sarcastic prophecies but in some
sense that which they are engaging with
mathematics itself
the underpinnings of our physical
reality if you are going to adopt a max
chegmark's view
of what physics is that's just
mathematics
that it itself is inherently a
stochastic process
that the quadratic equation it's not
just human mathematicians
whose confidence in the quadratic
equation
is um never 100
that actually the quadratic equation
itself in a if you're to adopt an almost
platinus view of mathematics this
external thing
that humanity is trying to get its hands
around
that it itself also is not 100 true but
is only squishy
what are the consequences
and that's what we're wrestling with in
that body of work
so professor
you mentioned that
you use the phrase for a reasonable
choice of
priors um so how does one
how do you because so here's what i'm
thinking the priors in some sense when
you're doing bayesian reasoning it
doesn't matter what matters is that you
update it in accordance to a certain
model so then you want your posteriors
to be a certain amount let's say you
want to be 99 certain of a certain fact
is it not true that you can then change
your priors
so like
let me figure out how to phrase this
you're spot on the prior essentially
essentially you can always change the
priors to give you any posterior
probability that you want you can
reverse the equation and then correct
okay
you're correct and that's related to the
no free lunge theorems
um another way of phrasing this is why
sociologically
um bayesian reasoning fell into very ill
repute
around the beginning of the 20th century
and that's why i'm a fisher
and other fellow travelers they came up
with things like
hypothesis testing confidence intervals
all that kind of stuff
was called sampling theory statistics
became ascendant and bayesian reasoning
fell into disrepute because people
misused it by choosing priors that were
leading to
results that kept coming up wrong and
bayesian reasoning is a matter of
garbage in garbage out
to push it even further
there is no way
that anybody's even imagined that you
can somehow prove
what the priors
are what they should be how you should
reason
there are
heuristics people like to use what's
called uninformative priors what are
called jeffrey's priors
ed james in his book the logic of
science and many of his
i use the phrase fellow travelers
they will try to say that your priors
that it behooves you to choose priors
that accurately
reflect the precise forms of ignorance
that you have about assist scenario
um
that's nice
seems reasonable they've not proven that
injunction
it's just they're taking it almost as a
feature of good practice
um
one might dispute it and even if one
does not dispute it
it's only going to get you so far there
are many scenarios where just what you
might mean by
quantifying my ignorance as a prior is
not at all clear
so yeah so we are in a certain sense the
nofee lunge theorems are saying this
by um
one way of to view
one of their contents
is
that if i have any particular reasoning
algorithm be it in say the machine
learning algorithms
or optimization algorithms evolution
itself any of which is a search
algorithm
and if i find that of my two algorithms
a and b
that for one set of priors a
outperforms b
so it's going to make more accurate
predictions about whether the sun will
rise tomorrow or what have you
that foreign for there is always going
to be just as many priors
for which b beats right okay way of
taking your intuition and
not only quantifying your intuition
but also
um
elaborating that it's more than just one
teeny little squirrely
if you want to be a naysaying
um annoyance you can find a counter
example it's saying no it's not just
that there's one prior in which the
conclusion that you want to reach
is counterfeited
rather there's just as many
in which that conclusion is wrong is
which they are in which it is correct
when you say justice much more than just
a single one when you say just as many
you mean in terms of this that
decide in the no freelance well yes
exactly so
it's a um
the no free lunch theorems are stated in
the following way they say that if i
take a
in the scenarios to which they apply you
can have a
a prior itself um
you can define a probability
distribution over priors
and you can say let's let's just
mathematically it's a mathematical trick
say there's a uniform distribution over
priors
then i can say that on average where i'm
averaging over that distribution over
priors
any two algorithms perform the same
so that means that if i find one
particular set of priors
whose measure
under that uniform distribution is such
that it that algorithm beats a a beats b
under that set of priors
then there's another set which has equal
measure under this uniform distribution
so you yes it's the same number but
number is being defined very precisely
in terms of a
probability distribution it's it's we're
talking about infinite spaces as a thing
so it's not just counting oh there's
three priors for which a beats b and
three priors which b beats a
it means the size of the set
of um
in a volume sense by which a beats b is
the same as which b beats a i didn't
know that your theorem had
something to say about basic and
reasoning or it used bayesian reasoning
in it whenever i hear people speak about
basic reasoning they hold it as this
pinnacle of rational thinking and
generally people who are
who like you mentioned in email which we
can remove this part where he said there
are certain people who try to sound as
if they're extremely intellectual
they say it as if it's iron clad however
the process may be a rational process
but the outcome
you can reverse engineer your priors to
give you whichever outcome you like and
i've always found that so why is it that
people
keep stating well look i'm a skeptic i
update my priors i do so and so yeah and
so therefore i've arrived at the correct
result i don't think that's the case and
i haven't heard anyone make a claim
otherwise until now right now just
extemporizing with you
yup so the way so this is i've even got
paper saying like what do the no
freelance theorems really mean people
even though
me and my collaborators we produced the
theorems we were very very explicit
about this
people misconstrue this
misconstrue their significance
the
simplest version of the no freelance
theorem says that if you have a
uniform prior
then all algorithms perform the same
but as we very um uh quickly then
uh
follow that in our papers by saying that
we can extend this by saying if you have
a uniform distribution over priors
then all two algorithms are the same so
we are not and we do not we're very
careful to say we do not advocate that
the the there is the prior is uniform
and we're not advocating that actually
you're allowing priors to vary but that
there is a uniform distribution over
priors that's not our point
our point is rather that
a uniform distribution over priors
is a mathematical tool by which one can
actually formally prove
what kurt just intuited
that is the significance it's not that
we are saying
there is a uniform prior over priors
um or that there is simply a uniform
prior uniformity is a tool by which we
are which we are using to quantify the
fact
that if a beats b in some situations
then b beats a in just as many and we're
using this uniformity to be able to
quantify what that just as many means
so many people will say that oh well i
don't think that the actual prior when
i'm doing my machine learning algorithm
is uniform therefore no free lunch is
irrelevant
no because you've got to justify
whatever the implicit prior is that you
do use
and no free lunches what it's telling
you is that they're going to be just as
many other ones for which you're screwed
as for which you succeed
that's what it truly means its
significance extends far beyond the case
it doesn't suffice for you
the naysayer to simply say i don't agree
with the uniform prior therefore no
freelancers are relevant you're missing
the point of no free lunch when you say
that
it's much more it's a way of formalizing
and elaborating
kurt's intuition which should be the i
guess the title of the new paper
why should anyone care about the no free
lunch theorem
because they formalize kurt's intuition
because
there are no let me let me
elaborate because you are correct that
people
um carefully say that according to
savage's axioms differenties axioms
cox's axioms the many axiomatizations of
rational reasoning
which will lead you to say you should
update your
priors according to
bayes theorem which is it's not even a
theorem it's really just the definition
of conditional probability
um it shouldn't be glorified to be
called a theorem but
you are exactly correct that yes once
you have arrived at your priors
if you then for the rest of your life
using those priors want to be rational
you should be bayesian
if by being rational you mean you obey
these particular axioms of these various
people have come up with
but that does not mean
anything about what those priors should
be in the first place
it just means that you've got a
well-designed machine that takes garbage
in and produces garbage out
it does that very very cleanly and
efficiently doesn't change the fact that
garbage in becomes garbage out
you're just not adding any more garbage
what's strange is that if we have no
assumptions on the underlying input
space or the underlying space then
when we're speaking about strategies if
i'm to think of evolution as employing
strategies or organisms as employing
strategies it seems like what your
theorem would state is that
evolution would have equally produced
any strategy however when i look around
it doesn't seem like any is equally
viable oh what accounts for that yup but
here's the thing it's just like that i'm
warning at the bottom of a prospectus
for a mutual fund that past performance
is not indicative of future performance
it's also true in that i can save i've
got a repeated test it's like the sun
rising
my data set
is just every time in the past let's say
it's very hard to actually quantify that
um natural selection um mutation with
descent and so on
whether it is actually being efficient
or not
because natural selection in the real
world
has its some of its true power is the
fact that it is obscenely
parallel computation
the number of actual different genomes
are right now out in the environment
that are flooding around evolving
um uh even if you don't include things
like viral genomes
it's you know whatever it's going to be
far far larger than the number of stars
in the universe you know that kind of
numbers and when you've got that kind of
parallelism advantage
almost any dumbass algorithm is going to
be able to do well so it's not even
clear that in any sense um evolution has
quote done well in our past
but even if it has
past performance is not indicative of
future performance that's what no
freelance theorem is quantifying all
those
even if it were true if you wanted to
say
every time i ran the experiment which
can have a bit up or down
up means evolution did well in this
situation down meaning it did poorly
even if i've run that experiment
huge number of times and each time i
kept coming the result evolution does
well evolution does well evolution as
well
no free lunch is saying that when we now
extrapolate off training set
to situations we have not seen before
anything can happen
and that's the crucial thing about no
free lunch is that it's not saying
anything about situations you've already
seen it's saying things about what's
called off training set new situations
it's all about generalization it's not
about
if i memorize things
and i know that what i've seen is not is
never going to change
and i asked and you were then asked well
um what is it that um
that you saw
in that situation well you answer and
you're correct memorization is fine the
question is always generalization to ask
what is it that you will see
that's where probabilities come into
play
that's where bayesian reasoning comes
into play and that's where no free lunch
comes into play we're going to get to
cross validation in about maybe five
minutes or so and as i mentioned to you
over email i'm a philosophical person
i'm an introspective person and i was
wondering with regard to the no free
lunch theorem does that imply that
there's no optimal strategy for one's
life
what i mean is
people including myself perhaps i'm
mainly speaking about myself have regret
over
the past and squandered opportunities
feeling like feeling like i didn't
implement the optimal strategy i haven't
lived up to my potential
now is that a valid concern or is your
theorem nihilistic where it doesn't
matter what you do
it doesn't seem it seems like it it it
matters what people do so it seems like
there is something to be said about
maximizing on one's potential as it will
defined as that sounds
um
when i was younger when i had just come
up with the no free lunch theorems in my
scribblings to myself that concerned
philosophical matters
i would have something that i eventually
abbreviated as
tp
and that came that was an abbreviation
of the problem
and that referred to
given no free lunch what in the world do
i do
um
how old were you
at
oh um
actually my first intimations of the
problem
were as an undergrad before i formalized
the no free lunch
um when i was worrying over these things
um
it actually did not fall into despair
perhaps i should have um
every time i walk across the street
i am behaving with my life on the line
as though no free lunch were wrong
every time i do anything
um
so i would say that in a certain sense
far more deeply than feelings of regret
no free lunch theorem has to do with how
i tie my shoes
it's how do i even exist and
how do you act how do you act and
so i look at this and i say okay
now what
um and here's how to make it even
worse and another thing i i guess
through my career i've not sort of
thought of myself this way but i tend to
have these
no-go-ish
kinds of
bent of finding out
to me it's one of the most glorious
i don't know this almost sounds buddhist
to me is one of the most glorious
aspects of
i wouldn't even use the word existence
the more that i am squashed flat the
more that i am seen to be
a teeny little restricted nothing
that to me is
the the height of beauty
that to me is the most
sublime and rapturing thing to sit on
your back in a meadow at night and to
just
look up and to try to project and
realize all those stars are
three-dimensionally configured
and just go through like a powers of ten
kind of a thing
to fully
to try to fully appreciate my own
insignificance
my own limitations that to me is the
most beautiful liberating thing i can
imagine
and these results all have that
character to them that they are in some
sense
precisely because i am not even a gnat
on the back of a fly that produces a
sense of joyful glee almost like a boy
or our child does oh i have liberated i
don't have to go to
you or whatever but there anyway this is
a preamble to another
set of results that are along the same
lines really
which are what are sometimes referred to
nowadays as the block
model of cosmology
um
[Music]
which is the
following um so i had a paper that was
published
um i guess i was a grad student at the
time at um
what was called the international
journal theoretical physics
uncalled
so okay there's there's various notions
of what's called the arrow of time
there's um one of them is the second law
of thermodynamics
and another one is what is sometimes
called psychological arrow of time the
notion that it feels to us as though
time is going forward
um paul davies had a very nice book on
this called the arrow of time in like 73
which is
um
it's not for popular audiences it's very
much a um
a forum
students of physics
but
the there is no such
in
when we talk about movement in space we
talk about position against time
to talk about movement and time you
would need to have two dimensions of
time
we don't
the future and the past in this is the
lesson of quantum mechanics really and
of general relativity they are
just as real as the present
there is no physical variable that can
actually distinguish
these things from one another
okay but so why do we have the illusion
that time seems to be moving forward
and it's actually can be
drilled down to being a two-step process
first
notice that you as a human being
you have memory of your past but you
have none of your future
a more precise way of phrasing that is
that you can
[Music]
retrodict what happened in the past more
accuracy than you can predict
what will happen in the future
you then drill down and try to say well
why might that be the case
and eventually you can actually make
arguments which are only informal to
this day
that um it's got to do the second law of
thermodynamics
but the reason i bring all this up is
that in a certain sense it's only worse
because whenever you
kurt are making these arguments about
what you've observed in your past and
your memories and your regret
that's actually only retrodiction you
don't even know for sure that those
things even happened
you only exist in the present
or simultaneously the presence in all
the futures with no
certainly no kind of a free will um
that you can somehow
supervene into all this and supersede
all of this and
change the way it is it's the book has
been written
and you are simply a single um page in
the book
um remembering the pages in the past as
best you can and wondering about the
pages in the future
that is all on top of
no free lunch the restrictions of
inference devices
and so on and so forth
there's
even before you get to the sort of
traditional concerns of metaphysics
about what is reality
there are all these nuances that prevent
you from actually in a certain sense
even getting to be able to sit up and
ask that question in the first place
um it's a very very strange thing and
i'm not sure how to actually deal with
it
okay so we're going to talk about free
will which it sounds like what you just
mentioned is
against free will yet you're one of the
largest proponents of the existence of
free will that i know of so we'll talk
about that soon because i'm sure you're
defining free will differently than the
way most people think of it
now you also mentioned that
this merriment that you have
as an adult and perhaps even as a child
is when you think about your
insignificance and just like you see
people like sabine haasenfelder as
intellectually posturing when they
dismiss free will
when i hear people say what you just
said also lawrence krauss expressed a
similar sentiment that well the more i
think about my ephemeral nature the more
that i feel like there's meaning because
there's a temporal temporary nature to
this i see this as a form of of rational
posturing to show like look how much i
don't need my importance but i'll
explain why and then please push back
i'm i just want to hear what your
thoughts are on this
because
if one takes that argument seriously
well look how limited our life is and
then that makes it more meaningful well
why don't you just kill your child make
your life make the your child's life
smaller is that not more meaningful or
maybe it's that we have to say that
because the alternative that you're
extremely extremely important in every
single thing you do matters beyond
what you can imagine maybe that's way
too crushing and so the alternative that
okay great i don't have this burden or
onus
that's freeing but it's not actually a
rational assessment that led you to that
freeing feeling it's more well the
alternative i don't it's a horror show
to think about how
meaningful and important my life is to
other people into the world and perhaps
well
let's hear what you have to say to that
i never use the word meaningful that
those other people they do
then make the argument that though okay
therefore i must make meaning out of
what i have and that then imbues it with
more significance
no
you are not this is the rhetorical you
you have no meaning you have no
significance
and when i say that this is
liberating and induces a feeling of glee
environment that's an aesthetic
reaction
so
um
it was
when i first
came to feel that it was
shortly after i first learned quantum
physics this was when i was
a teenager and i think people
misconstrue the true significance of
quantum physics they talk about the
uncertainty principle wave particle
duality
yes that's all really cool but the
more important
aspect of it i think lesson of it
is precisely the um
establishment of the tag marketing view
that
all that a reality is is a mathematical
system that there is nothing outside of
that
that in quantum mechanics what you find
when you do it
is that you cannot do any of your
predictions on properly unless both the
observer and the system being observed
are both in an inclusive way treated
quantum mechanically
the vigner and all these other people
this is almost like this is an everett
view which is the one that's really
adopted whether they want to admit it or
not by everybody working like quantum
computation and so on there is no
external observer everything
um sean carroll has you know also is a
good is a effective proponent of this if
there is no external observer you don't
need to invoke
something beyond just the mathematics
itself
to be able to give all phenomena that we
can experimentally assess
once you do that and you start to
realize that oh well ultimately
one mathematics is just as legitimate as
another one
so if a reality is just a body of
mathematics
that means other bodies of mathematics
are just as real as this one as physical
universes
in any case it was contemplating that
and the associated feelings of
insignificance that this was an
aesthetic response of mine and it was
only then
up until that point whenever i had
thought about
zen buddhism haiku koans anything like
that
spiritualism
i'd always been very dismissive of it um
very much of a standard
westerners maybe you're going to be
respectful and public but it's got
nothing to say for you personally
um
i am still very dismissive of some
aspects of buddhism
for example
buddhism is supposedly all about the
irrelevance of the self
but in fact in practice at least
buddhist practice is all working on the
self so that i get to understand how i'm
irrelevant and that's a
massive contradiction in the foundations
but here's the thing that happened
once i
started to try to internalize this
lesson of quantum mechanics
and notions along the lines of no free
lunch
now for the first time i could actually
appreciate aesthetically
some of the products of zen buddhism
zen buddhism watercolors zen buddhism
and then buddhist gardens
i started to be able to appreciate koans
not as deep spiritual work but as
aesthetic works as works of art
as closer to um poems somewhat like
haiku are normally perceived yeah i saw
you wrote some haikus on your website
um yeah oh some short things yeah i've
got some stuff there along those lines
do you see yourself as i don't mean to
interrupt please hold your thought but
do you see yourself as an artist
more than a mathematician
um
i don't
i don't actually characterize myself
that way when i was
younger trying to figure out what i want
to be when i grow up in a very practical
concrete sense what i want to have as my
major and so on
i would say things to myself like
i approach science as a philosopher i
approach philosophy as a mathematician i
kind of approach
math as an artist things like that um
like an orboros kind of a thing um
i have no
delusions that i am
well okay another kind of this is
interesting this conversation's going up
much to sort of lessons of life kind of
thing
one of the tragedies i find of people's
lives around me all the time
and what i very intensely viciously
among the guard with that i do not
indulge in myself
is inflated views
of your own abilities your own worth
your own capabilities what you are
providing this has got nothing to do
with oh my beautiful insignificance this
is just i've seen tragedies where people
think that they have the capabilities to
engage in something and they
change how they're living their lives
along those lines and really know that
was a
misassessment of what they can do
when they began
and therefore there's frustrated
expectations and so on and so forth yes
your reach must always exceed your grasp
etc but if you're not really aware of
what the grasp is in the first place
you're running a real large risk that
you're going to be unsuccessful in that
reach of yours
the reason i mention all that is i'm
very aware of what my own limitations
are
i personally do not view the
material on my website as
necessarily worthy of
comparison
to those of a real artist or poet
i don't even necessarily i don't view
myself as actually all that smart as a
scientist
there are many
i am aware of what my relative strengths
are
um but in terms of just raw iq
that ain't one of them there's people
out there who are far smarter and far
better as scientists in that sense
well you have a clever saying on your
website that you're not
you're not intelligent enough to be a
mathematician nor careful enough to be
an experimentalist is that correct
yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's for my website yep
okay now you were talking about how
quantum physics allowed you to
appreciate zen cohen's
and then you're saying aesthetically
and not spiritually necessarily and i
interrupted you so do you mind finishing
that thought um
yeah so as i say i don't view
i don't think
it's sometimes construed as a philosophy
and i think as a philosophy buddhism has
nothing to say i think it like all
religions are just
vacuous fables that humans come up with
to try to
comfort themselves against
the big vast expanse which is what i
actually for whatever weird reasons in
my psyche i actually find
so beautiful it's most people most
reasonable people react with some
screaming fear and i think that's the
basis of a lot of religion
um you can also actually there's a lot
of very interesting literature in the
economics field economics or religion
um it's actually very very interesting
as a topic of study um what makes some
religions succeed and other ones not
and of course it goes back many people
have worried about have wondered about
um right as evolutionary theories of why
humans have religion
so construed as a religion i view
buddhism like the other ones as
at best
um epiphenomena side effects of other
processes that go on and certainly do
not have any
legitimacy as philosophies concerning
reality whatever you might want reality
to be
as as bodies of aesthetics as art
that is what i could suddenly appreciate
um when i started to um understand
quantum physics and no free lunch and so
on i don't know why
i've not really drilled down on this
much but somehow
the
this is probably almost like a
convergent evolution that the
evisceration of the notion of the worth
of the self that i arrived at it my
processing based upon science
induced the same kind of aesthetic
reaction in me
as the evisceration of self that
buddhists undergo for their reasons
induced in them
so it's probably got more to do to say
about how human psyches
react to that
cognitive
assessment
even though the ways that those
cognitive assessments are arrived at is
very very different and i would frankly
argue long and hard
that one is legitimate being grounded in
science and the other one is not being
grounded in
obsession with self i would say um
anyway
at this point there were some technical
difficulties with the zoom and the audio
takes a decrement and improves in a few
minutes the view that you outlined about
religion reminds me of marx's opiate for
the masses where it's just there simply
to placate the society and i'm curious i
don't want to get on a tangent about
religion nor
well i don't want to get on a tangent
about religion so if you can briefly
comment on this why do you think it is
that many of the religions have a huge
element of hell in them which is
actually terrifying so if it was just
about
making people feel better for me when i
made a conversion to being being an
atheist and i know this from virtually
every atheist i've spoken to there's a
huge moral weight that's lifted from you
when you convert quote unquote to
atheism so it's not as if one is happier
necessarily simply because of the
the teachings of the religion it's not i
don't think it's as simple as that and
i'd like to hear what you have to say
about them yes no i fully agree with you
um
for me there was never a moral weight
personally for what it's worth there's
never a moral weight being concerned
about um after lodge or anything like
that
um there's actually some very
interesting literature that those
religions which are most successful
um in the history of religion this has
to do with the economic religion
literature
there are those that make the most
demands of their practitioners
religions that don't make much
much in the way of demands as opposed to
those that do demand things like you go
on a missionary
um
or that you give a large tithe or they
very very much
change what your
daily routine is
those ones tend to be much more
successful so you've got the religions
that are successful
are those that are particularly
demanding
um so there are these kinds of
counter-intuitive aspects to religion as
far as the one about
whether
some so marx of course with the opiate
for the masses he was instead talking
about its large
sociological implications and how he
thought it was being exploited
as opposed to personally
why someone might be taken to be
[Music]
um
vested in the notion of an
anthropomorphic religion as opposed to
spiritualism if you mean by spiritualism
something closer to aesthetics there
one could say that i personally am very
spiritualist
it's much more a matter of the
supernatural
um why and the aspect of things now
it's not
it it is not certainly
[Music]
the reason that people are
inclined to
supernaturalism in general
is not simply as a comforter
there is that element to it
but certainly many religions do not
provide any comfort
um traditional catholicism for example
was you're born into sin and
you you might be screwed at birth and
that's the way it is
um
[Music]
so it is far more
complicated than the um
kind of snide comments i was making i
think that for many people in modern
society
the role it plays is a comforter
historically and cross-culturally
religion has played many many other
roles
wound up with supernaturalism
which is itself wound up with our
tendency to over generalize the
environment
thing
things like if you are evolving here's
one simple argument in favor of why we
are prone to supernaturalism
if i'm evolving human beings in the felt
a million years ago hominins
um i can either have them be over
generalizing
um finding patterns where there are no
patterns or under generalizing
if you're over generalizing you might
think that a particular rustle in the
grass always means there's a tiger there
when that's not true
but you're going to be a lot better off
than someone who's under generalizing so
that when there is a pattern that's
related to whether there's a tiger in
the grass
they don't
draw the proper conclusion and therefore
they get eaten
so you can make those kinds of arguments
as to why we are prone to um
supernaturalism in the first place why
we do tend to find patterns where there
aren't any there
and
the deep psychological
[Music]
compulsions
that have resulted in religions many of
which have
[Music]
no
[Music]
emollient
characteristic to them at all exactly as
you're saying
those ones
are not
the ones that i see so prevalent in
modern american society
so when i made my statements which were
snide and globe and off the cuff
i was referring much more
to modern
right-wing religious sentiments
where i do think it's
you know there are all these studies
that say that those who are very
religious
in the modern sense of the word
going to um engaging in
the march of the world in terms of the
modern church
that they live eight years longer and
things like this because the stress
levels of them are so much reduced
so i'm much more referring to that
cohort
um and their approach to life
then i am true religion as is occurring
across all societies and across all time
at this point there was a minor break
and we started to talk about sabine
haasenfelder there was no exact question
otherwise i'd leave it here it's simply
the topic of his thoughts on sabine's
video about super determinism and free
will
i guess
so she's got an axe to grind she wants
to there to be hidden variable models
she they want reality to be that way she
and some other people
and so they are searching around for any
way that they can
to try to find squirrel room where
belle's
in her case belster i'm not withstanding
you can still have a hidden variable
model
and
i just don't see the point it's
motivated reasoning
[Music]
um
to
she says it's super free will as that i
view as
vacuous because that's just what she is
arguing for is just what i would always
have considered to be sorry
is super i forget what her perception
super determinism super determinism
that's right super determinism it's kind
of like a super version of no free will
super determinism is just what i had
always understood to be standard
physics
straight out of the box um
i'm not quite sure why she is trying to
make a case she and others
make a case that somehow something new
it's much more that they v what they are
trying to
it's a strange thing what physicists
mean by free will like in conway's free
will theorem and so on
it's kind of distorted from what the
term is normally meant in the
larger in the parlance of philosophers
more generally
and anyway as i say i think it's
motivated reasoning
how about we define free will or you
define free will and then tell the
audience what your inference theorems
have to say about free will you'll have
to define free will and also define what
your inference theorem is and then what
the inference theorem has to say about
free will okay so um
first a warning there is a
unfortunate tendency it should have a um
particular name as one of the rhetorical
fallacies it's you know the ad hominem
policy the this fallacy the that fallacy
for people to take a term that's in very
common use
and is very controversial because of all
these reasons
they want to establish that it's true
so they redefine it in a certain way
that they can establish that true
that redefinition
all of the original reasons that are so
controversial
they are now defined out
and what you're left with is actually a
very different kind of a concept
and they now then herald it and say oh
look
i've just proved such and such where
what they've really done is redefined it
in such a way that they could prove it
but all the reason people were
interested in the first place is now out
of their new definition so it's a bait
and switch
the fallacy is called martin bailey i
believe
martin bailey okay um how's that spelled
m-o-t-t-e
and then bailey's as the drink i believe
essentially you mean so you take some
fact and then you're straw manning it
and you use the straw man to disprove
the larger one
yeah or or to prove it as the case might
be martin bailey's that's nice i've got
to look that up later so continue
so yes so um for example um okay so
certainly if you're familiar with the
concept
um the notion of god has been treated
that way
um you know many people say oh einstein
really believe in god because you know
he said the laws of nature and so the
rules of nature is god um
but of course the reason that
god is considered to be a controversial
topic is because it's a banana promo for
morphized
it's this dude in the sky with a big
beard who's deciding who's going to win
the football game sunday night
um and
that's the one that's controversial and
so on and so forth and einstein wasn't
saying anything about in favor of that
particular one um
so it's a little bit of a modern balance
and frankly
um i think that he has done some great
work and he's a
good friend and a great guy but i think
that dan dennett was recently um
involved in this with um free will
he hum wrote a book and which he tries
to now claim i've proven free will and
in essence he's defined a way it's
aspects that made it controversial in
the first place
so
what do i mean by free will um there's a
there's one aspect to it which is that
which would be that of the people who
write dictionaries what does it mean in
common discourse
and what i think free will means and
common discourse has something to do
with
a means by which
it is possible to
abrogate the laws of deterministic
science
in such a way that a human's cognitions
are not
subject to those laws
so that what is going on in your head
right now is not
some very complicated too complicated to
calculate but nonetheless
um uh
inviable function
of what it was you were thinking 10
seconds ago together with the stimuli
sensory stimuli from your environment
but somehow there's something else
that is not subject to any laws of
science in some sense it's not even
subject to stochastic laws it's just
amorphous and ill-defined and
in that and so certainly all of us
have a um subjective experience of such
a thing
um but the proponents of free will in
this country in this um sense which is
controversial would say that no it's
actually an objective truth
um i don't see that there's any room for
that to be quite honest um so in that
sense no i don't if that's what
if we do adopt that kind of a definition
which i think isn't according with the
way it's used in
common parlance no i don't see it
there's any room for such a thing you
can you can maybe kind of get close and
scott aronson again he's involved
engaged in a martin bailey's in this
particular paper of his
but he and even more worse martin
bailey's as seth lloyd they try to make
the case that turing machine notions of
computability
provide a way out in that they say that
yes it might be
the various flavors of the argument but
one version of it is
yes the
present state of your mind is a
deterministic function of what it was
and so on but it's an uncomputable
function
in some technical senses
yeah stephen wolfram says something
similar where he uses his term
computational irreducibility and says
well yes there are outcomes that are
computationally irreducible and that's
where free will may live but ultimately
you don't have control over the laws
it's still a deterministic step-by-step
algorithmic process
yeah um and in a certain sense it's kind
of interesting because
one might ask in terms of the laws of
science or physics or how the universe
actually evolves
is there any room for anything besides
deterministic or stochastic evolution
i can write down the definition
you can go look it up in math textbooks
whereas stochastic processes
and you can look up in math textbooks
what a deterministic convertible process
is
i mean you can actually formulate the
one is a special case of the other
is there any way you can even in theory
imagine
science that would not be either random
or deterministic is anything else it
could possibly be
and there are notions in the original
motivation for um komogorov
in terms of his work in komodo
complexity
and many other people who are wondering
about intrinsic randomness
what does um complexity mean what does
random really mean
they came up with definitions which
is something that is random
but is not random it but it has no
probability distributions
so it's interesting to think about what
whether that might provide any kind of a
whether that's a difference without
significance or whether there is a
significance to that possibility
that physical systems might in essence
violate the physical church touring
thesis
and have
this kind of an uncomputable character
to them which is not random and it's not
deterministic but it's something
different and that whether that has any
kinds of consequences even if it's true
so that's interesting in almost like a
philosoph philosophy of science kind of
a way
but it really is i would say
irredeemably far from what people mean
by free will to really say that it's
relevant to the discussions that
people have about what free will is i
think for them
for the vast majority of what
philosophers have meant by it for
millennia
it's no it's certainly nothing to do
with komodo complexity and turing
machines and so on and so forth
it's simply the notion of their this
supernatural in the literal sense of
above nature above the laws of nature
which is inherent in me
and my soul and i cannot even define it
because it is something that's
non-definable
and that allows for
superseding of the laws of physics when
it comes to my own brain that's what is
sometimes meant
um i think that's most
fully what is
meant by people who are talking about
free will have been talking about
historically
and i almost view it as
a non-starter
okay so to make a summary for the
audience who just wants a clear answer
do we have free will or not
in that sense i don't think it's even
meaningful to say that we do
um i don't see that you can
if you you almost by that definition one
is almost defining free will to be
something that's undefinable
and it our end is supernatural
and i
[Music]
can't even almost react to that as if
it's not definable i can't say anything
and if it's not
and i don't see there is a room for any
supernatural things in
all notions of reality
um circling back to a previous theme one
of the things i find most beautiful
about
the our inconsequentiality
is that the whole notion of
consciousness
it's a post hoc fable that we cook up to
try to give us the illusion that we're
in control of our own brains there's all
these fascinating
phenomena going about like ben liebert
and so on
demonstrating that it's at least um
logically consistent in fact seems to be
the case
that um all the things that we think
we're in control of we're we're not in
control in any meaningful sense of any
of them we're making enough stories
after the fact corpus closum
severed people going you know that whole
literature
it's fascinating that when you ask one
half of a brain why the other half is
doing what it is
that they cannot know they can factor
physically impossible but they think
that they do
with complete conviction the obvious
next step is how can i believe
what reason do i have for believing that
my conviction
that i'm in control is any more
legitimate than that of the hemisphere
that's in it's convict
that it's in control
so let me steel man the opponent so with
regard to the supernatural
most
religious people
would say that there is no supernatural
well let's forget about most religious
people there is the view that there is
no supernatural even in the religious
domain
that god operates by natural law in fact
god is natural law and then we may say
well god is supposed to be a man in the
sky etc however that wasn't the case up
until about 200 or 300 years ago at
least it wasn't the majority case and
mysticism christian mysticism in
particular was extremely rampant where
you can't define god attempts to do so
are actually
considered to be sinful because any
instantiation of god is going to not
incorporate what god truly is so god's
left somewhat ill-defined that we can
communicate with it maybe not in a
propositional sense like we write down
words maybe in a felt sense regardless
there's no supernatural so whatever
exists whether they're ghosts or psychic
phenomena that's a natural phenomenon it
just isn't incorporating the natural
sciences currently so there's no above
nature and i agree that this is what
free will should be defined as there's
somehow
us interacting with nature that is
different than
just the physical laws we know it so
it's a metaphysical statement when we
think that we have free will and then
you are saying yeah it would have to be
supernatural because it's above the laws
of physics well
remus malian i'm sure you've heard of
reemus million the mathematician he had
many writings on free will and he would
say
what defines you what's the difference
between you and natural law you're a
product of natural on we tend to think
of free will as not existing because the
outside world is more powerful than us
and somehow despite our will
it just overcomes us however that would
mean that there's a distinction between
you and natural law well
that's illusory so in some sense you are
natural law so in some sense
but
well
they leave it there
so what is the meaning of free will is
it just a psychological phenomenon that
people have this sense of agency yeah
sure that's definitely true that half of
a hemisphere thinks it's in control of
the other one
and yeah there's all kinds of
is there a psychological phenomenon just
like people can get depressed just like
people can become obsessive-compulsive
just like much more commonly everybody
yours truly as well
feels has this feeling
that you're in control yes and it's
interesting maybe to look at some of the
neurobiology behind some of that
but if that's what the statement is
then yeah it's definitely true just go
do a survey do people feel this way yeah
they would do
if instead it's a statement about
metaphysics to say it's natural law
i would say as a martin bailey you're
ending up with nothing
so then what do you mean by free will if
you don't mean this um
part of neuropsychology
if you're going to say that is just
part of determining what is it
there's nothing left to define it as i
would say
even the lipid experiments you mentioned
the limited experiments libit says that
his
and i would like to interview him
i don't know if he's still alive i think
he's not and by the way those are now
controversial those experiments yeah and
libit himself was a proponent of free
will and says that his experiments have
been interpreted incorrectly i find it
to be controversial whenever someone
says free will exists or free will
doesn't exist i'm curious like how are
you making that without a plethora of
assumptions it's also a metaphysical
claim we both agree it's a metaphysical
claim and maybe you don't agree with
this but i don't think science makes
metaphysical claims i think science is
an instrument and if anything it's
instrumentalism here's what science is
just if then statements it says if you
do this this happens it doesn't say
behind this is an electron per se says
our models indicate so and so and when
we do this we get the result that we
want do you take this instrumental view
of science or do you feel like science
actually has claims on
what exists and what doesn't exist so
here's a way to cut the gordian knot um
so i think i think we're agreed that
free will i view it as either
photological in the sense that if it is
a
psychoneuropsychological phenomenon then
people do have that feeling of free will
yes they do
um just like people have a feeling of
being happy or sad
and these are things that you that
neurobiologists can
put people into fmri scanners and try to
drill down if it is instead viewed as a
metaphysical statement then i don't know
what it means
um
and that might in fact some people might
define to be enough as me unless we try
to go across some
turing computability and so on
um
now
in terms of whether science is anything
to say about metaphysics
um
[Music]
what i mean is does science ever make a
claim to ontology instrumentalism or not
yeah yeah i mean it's a subtle thing is
so instrumentalism
one way to interpret it and like all
names of schools and philosophy it's got
various flavors and proponents and so on
but it's the view that there is some
ill-defined reality out there
which produces
effects on our experimental apparatuses
and what science is
is a way of trying to actually relate
the patterns in those effects in our
apparatuses
and maybe make predictions about other
patterns we might see in future
apparatuses
without saying anything about this
underlying physical reality
that an electron is a construct
for
um describing these patterns but and
there is some other external reality out
there
that it does
the word electron is not necessarily
relevant to it at all
um
and certainly since science
in its current
institution is progressing
it could not make any claim that it is
reality
but here's a different perspective which
is implicit in what's called antic
structural realism
um also in some of max tegmark's more
careful work and like his analyst of
physics paper
and so on rather than his pop work
and which also underlies some of the
ways that my collaborate and i've been
promoting the have been
pushing
the formalism and noise deterministic
reasoning
there
which also relates to what i was talking
about before the the problem so here is
a very simple
not that simple but here is a
hypothesized
mathematics
which in welding fell swoop explains
all explains away all of the conundrums
of philosophy
together with science
and here it is
it's only mathematics all the way down
that there is no external reality
everything is just a mathematical system
and that one mathematical system is in
fact just as legitimate as just as real
as any other one
is that the reason a chess piece on a
chessboard
feels the laws of chess to be real
rather than the laws of checkers
is simply because it's happening to
right now be um uh viewed as a token in
a game of chess but it could just as
easily be any of checkers
from that perspective then there is a
mathematical system
which would have as
some of its equations
human beings
looking out
at experimental universes around them
and noticing patterns
which might be approximations in some
sense or not
of this underlying mathematics but
underlying it all
is just that mathematics
so it's somewhat stepping to the side of
saying
there is no re
it's a single mono
monolithic edifice
that explains both philosophies humans
our instruments the patterns and
underlying reality
it's all just one single thing
and there is no room for anything else
it is informed by
science
but it is not actually somehow something
that is proven by science
you know how you said that you're unsure
what it means for free will to have the
metaphysical notion of free will what
the heck does that mean
i'm not sure what it means
that mathematics is the ultimate reality
i don't understand max tegmark's ideas
and i'm also unsure if you're
claiming that you like those ideas and
that's the one that you see
i was fitting reality most
i view it as
in one fell swoop solving
well it doesn't completely solve the the
conundrums because for example the laws
of mathematics
um girdles and completeness theorem says
there is no um the ultimate
um unviable
consistency in the laws of mathematics
themselves so
it eats its own tail
and if one then says noisy
deductive reasoning
you then get an even worse visceration
of the foundations of that statement
that all is mathematics it disappears
what do you mean there's no such thing
as a mathematics
but here's the sense in which so those
are extra
[Music]
extensions of the underlying first
concept which i which are very very
important but before getting to them
before invoking girdle and so on
um
[Music]
i view antic structural realism
techmarks elaborations as explaining it
all in the sense of quantum physics
that
you curt
are part of a wave function
that involves the screen you're looking
at and everything else it's the wave
function of the universe
and all aspects of your neurobiology and
therefore your subjective notion of free
will
all aspects of your scrutinizing the
results of experiments involving
what in your lab notebook is called an
electron
all of that is arising
as simply solutions to in a to
schrodinger's equation
and that there is nothing else besides
that there is no underlying concrete
reality
that your mathematics is describing
it suffices to just dispense with it you
don't need that concrete reality all is
mathematics it is not the mathematics we
currently have in our textbooks
but that's fine because our textbooks
themselves are simply
some of the um
characteristics the projection operators
of the clause in quantum physics
of the wave function of the universe
um
have you ever heard the phrase
we shouldn't mistake the map for the
territory
i don't believe i've heard the phrase
yes
or it's actually it's sometimes the map
and the territory don't miss don't
mistake them right that's right what did
i say
you said the math and the charity no no
i meant the map if i misspoke yeah the
map of the territory because in that
case there's stuff that's not that's um
not in the
uh map that is in the territory you can
um experimentally ascertain that
this point is that um the map that we
currently have
is not the ultimate map
but the ultimate map so to speak the or
map
has in it this is almost like a
brazilian kind of a
image that's coming to the forehead
it's got in it as a little small part of
it
some people looking at their own little
cartoon maps
of the full map
and that is all that the territory is
the territory is itself a map
we have a map which should not be
mistaken for the map that is the
territory
how do we know how do we know that all
is math we don't i remember i was very
very careful the way to phrase this that
one perspective
which is consistent and simple
it doesn't invoke unseens
as since going back to kant at least
western philosophy has been prone to
doing
or plato for that matter with his
platonic ideals
it doesn't invoke all those unscenes
because it's pointing out
that
ultimately we are it's by flipping the
perspective to say that we
are phenomenal generated by it
rather than it is something external to
us that we are trying to understand
it's a flip of the perspective you start
with the it
and we are manifestations of it
projection operators as they call in
physics of little pieces of the it
rather than starting from ourselves and
almost like capernaum and pre-copernicus
copernican view of the earth as the
center we are the center trying to infer
the
outside territory no
we are ourselves just one small little
map in this much bigger map
and from that perspective you don't need
anything outside and everything is
explained all of these conundrums
you know no free lunch how does that
allow me to even get going
um yep you're correct little boy that no
free lunch doesn't allow you personally
to get going
but that doesn't change the fact that
here is a
way that
here is a i'm not even sure what you
would call it it's not saying it's a
reality it's not saying his hypothesis
it's just a
[Music]
edifice of
interrelated explanatory phenomena of
mathematics
which we don't even currently have
but
um which would actually do a jujitsu
move of all of our philosophical
conundrums
by simply saying that they are what come
up in the neurobiology of these
particular little systems that are being
generated as part of the solution to the
schrodinger equation when they try to
look outward at things outside of
themselves
sir how would you respond to my thought
which is it sounds like
we have quantities and then we say well
all that exists are these quantities and
not everything is quantitative however
it seems to that's what i mean when i
say that sorry that's my that's my
rendition of all is math
however it seems like there are large
classes of our experience which are
qualitative that don't lend themselves
at least not readily to quantity and to
me it sounds like a large statement to
say all of what we think of as
qualitative so anger the sight and the
experience of red and blue etc so you're
talking about qualia
yeah yeah not everything lends itself to
a quantitative analysis okay but are you
specifically talking about like chalmers
and these people their notion of what
they call qualia
sure
so i
view that
conundrum as ultimately
ultimately vacuous we think that we feel
something i mean famously uh dan danette
um had a great put down of the
people what does it feel like to be a um
hummingbird i think it was um that very
famous paper
um
then it eviscerates it but um ultimately
[Music]
the question what is it
i don't see if there's any room for that
question any more than there's any room
for our belief for one hemisphere's
belief that's in control of the other
one
that belief is
wrong it is demonstrably wrong
neurobiology
can presumably in some future
incarnation
[Music]
explain why
that hemisphere would come to that
conclusion after first neurobiology has
to even
figure out what it means to say that a
particular piece of
brain tissue is coming to a conclusion
or not
but it is wrong it is
got nothing to do with reality
that qualitative experience of that
hemisphere being controlled
no it's not
and but we can now expect this future
incarnation of neurobiology would be
able to explain all aspects
whatever question you might
ask of that subjective experience it
would be able to provide the answer
that there's not necessarily any room
for anything else
um
you said this has yet to be demonstrated
we just see you see this as reasonable
yes neurobiology has not done this
by a long shot
um but i'm just saying that what's
consistent
with everything that we now know with
everything that we can think
of
would be consistent with math it's i
find it
let me tell you my thoughts quickly i'm
sorry to interject
when it comes to neurobiology and then
we have neural correlates of certain
qualitative experiences and then you can
say those correlates are quantitative so
we found an association between the
quantitative and the qualitative so
therefore the qualitative ultimately
reduces to the quantitative those
ultimately rely on many many many many
many reports of subjective experiences
so for example i'll have to tell you
maybe 50 times
i'm thinking of my mother before you can
find the mother
neuron if such a pattern exists but you
get what i'm saying we can pretend that
it does
so that means that it relies so heavily
on the subjective experience and
repeated subjective experiences that
don't replicate between brains so you'll
have to take it so so it varies between
individuals
and then we're doing
um my
i wouldn't even say these are claims my
statements do not have to do with
current neurobiology
or even necessary that neurobiology will
get there
it's much more the following
it's a challenge
to you
if in fact
there is something inherent
about the subjective
that it
would not be reducible to
mathematical properties
given especially in light of the ben
liebert experiments
the split blade and all the other
related
zombie within kind of phenomena
how could one even speak about it
without reducing it to being a
mathematical thing what is even it
how can we even say anything
how can we have a discussion
[Music]
with unless it's going to be defined
precisely and i don't know how to define
something precisely
without defining it precisely it's
it's a challenge how do you
other than sitting around rather than
having an aesthetic experience
which we can have how do we actually
engage in it in a reasoning manner
without actually giving it
a definition that can be reasoned about
and i don't know how to do and i don't i
just view mathematics as essentially
the body of all that we can
or reasoning that we can do
i don't i don't see what else it could
be how we could even have a discussion
about it
let's have fun here when you're saying
that you don't know how we can speak
unless we define our words precisely
well
well well it seems as though
people have gotten by for thousands of
years without the invention of
mathematics
or formal systems et cetera and and
they've had some communication and then
when it comes to well
no no but i'm not saying
you and i can speak about viewing art
for example right now you've got a
guitar back there
i presume that you play
um
i don't wish i could but i i could
imagine that we could
have an interaction concerning music and
if
in a different life um
where those particular regrets returning
to a previous theme
did not exist to me i might be able to
have some facility on it and we could um
do it we could jam together
um or what not
um
that would be us communicating it would
all be legitimate it would be valid it's
a different form of communicating from
when we are trying to ascertain
jointly
using
reasoning processes
something concerning
i don't i wouldn't even use the word
existence because that by itself is a
fraud exercise but so it's a different
it's a different realm of discourse
you and i can very definitely
talk about what does it feel like to
experience beautiful music
what does it feel like to be read as a
simple-minded one but to experience
beautiful art
i have often described how to me
i have been ambushed in my life by
paintings
um turn a corner in a gallery or a
museum and literally the phrase that
keeps coming to my mind i keep repeating
is i'm being ambushed i am just knocked
flat
i'm stunned by it it's a physical
reaction by that by that actual painting
um to give you simple examples things
like monets and van gaal because it's so
beautiful that you're not
in particular i never particularly
appreciate cezanne and so when i first
saw one in the flesh
then it ambushed me because there's so
many details of it that just don't come
to reproduce well when you read about a
cesarean peace monster
simon sent i think it was
um in the art books
it's all intellectual that he had this
effect on art history and so on and so
forth okay so you can read it like that
but then when i saw it
wow
i was knocked out of my socks and more
generally i can talk with you or anybody
else about how for me to actually judge
a painting the way that i judge it the
process i go through
is what can it teach me
if i myself were trying to redo that
painting and try to change some things
would i actually learn no weights you
can't do that
because of these aspects that you
weren't even sensitive to
does it have its own three-dimensional
reality that painting or is it just a
flat caricature
i don't mean necessarily a sense of
perspective i mean does it
exist i understand
um so we can have that discussion
um does that have anything to do with
furniture's equation
well i mean you know ultimately if you
want to flip things around and yeah sure
david you can have a different set of
discussions
where you're saying that these aesthetic
experiences in your head are just
neurobiology and so on forth sure you
can and if you want to go off and do it
but that's a different conversation
we're having from talking about that art
piece ambushing me it's irrelevant to
talk about it in terms of schringer's
equation sure yes but who cares that's
got nothing to do with the actual
discussion we're having about what art
pieces have that they can teach you
conversely though
if i am instead in a different mood i've
woken up on a different side of the bed
and i'm discussing
philosophy
formal reasoning
what is the ultimate nature of reality
then
all of the other stuff about being
ambushed it just the question gets
reduced to
is all of that in theory at least
explainable or is there something there
that is not even in theory explainable
as being
a
meta as an epiphany an effect of
mathematical schrodinger's equation
it's a completely different way of of
engaging with
the same subject domain
and what i'm saying is that when i'm
over there wearing my metaphysics hat
if i'm just going to push metaphysics to
be what i
personally david walport i'm interested
in
which is all the way down the road
reasoning i see i see okay i see so let
me put it like this it sounds like what
you're saying is if one is making a
claim that
your brain david that you have some free
will and it supervenes the laws of
physics sorry it doesn't so physics
supervenes on that your free will
somehow determines the laws of physics
at least
momentarily enough for a neuron to fire
differently and so therefore you have
free will so you have some
your free will has some ontological
status and then you're saying well okay
where along the chain from electrons to
cells to
neurons to well a neuron is this type of
cell to the whole brain configuration to
your behavior where on that chain
was physical law broken because you can
look at any given one of those chains
and you can say well look at
there's no violation of physical law and
so if the nebulous person is making the
claim about some nebulous concept like
free will you'd better show me where it
comes in so far the laws of physics are
not violated at any level as far as
we've examined it is that what you're
saying
essentially yeah
um as opposed to do i have a feeling of
free will yes i do
okay now what i would say to that is i'd
still say that we don't know and i don't
think you're making the claim that you
know either so i don't think that we're
speaking differently let me put a bit of
a monkey wrench so when we look and we
examine any one of these features so we
look at let's say the electron bound
with a proton we say there are no laws
of physics being violated here this is
all explainable with what we have
currently as our models or at least we
have the idea that some other model may
exist in the future and then cells and
so on and so on it's as if you're
looking individually at small parts but
still
the counter claim could be that you show
me that the laws of physics are obeyed
for someone making a decision across the
whole spectrum and not looking at it
individually across different people in
different circumstances and saying here
it's not violated it would be almost as
if what you're doing is looking at a
small billiard balls bouncing around in
a small environment saying there's no
time here there's no time here there's
no time here but yet you're saying
you're saying that there's time at the
higher level there can be it can be
emerging i mean phil anderson's more is
different
you can have um laws that's what
condensed matter physics
is all about parisi just won you know
the nobel prize for um spin glass models
which is thermodynamic limit
an infinite number the phenomena that
arise strictly speaking only when you
have an infinite number of these
interactive models but it's all being
governed by mathematics
and
so um you're correct i'm not saying that
i now and maybe not humanity ever
would even be able to fill in all those
steps
um i'm saying that there is a consistent
picture
in which those steps are part of a
mathematics which may
forever more be beyond humans
but i'm then going a little bit further
and saying
[Music]
give me
provide for me anything other than
essentially an elaborated version of
describing the experience that you have
when looking at a beautiful painting
something that's got something
that
is not mathematics i don't even see what
one could call free will
other than and it's
i can
i just don't even understand what else
that could be
besides mathematics and then aesthetics
i don't see it there's
i i don't see how we can be doing
reasoning reasonably rigid
iron cloud we know that with the the
things that as i encourage you to come
up with
given um all the stuff about noise
deterministic reasoning
um
uh the deductive reasoning but how we
can actually come to any kinds of
conclusions
if we're not
using
logic let me say that second order logic
i mean that's part of
mathematics second order logic is part
of mathematics and i don't see how we
can
if we can't even define the terms
in something like what is called in
mathematical logic a
language where you've got an associated
um set of axioms and so on and so forth
i don't even see how we can be speaking
about it in those terms
i don't see what philosophy can be if
it's not that
i see when we were talking about how
some of these philosophical claims are
volutinous they're bleary they're opaque
dubious you don't know what the heck it
means because there's they're speaking
ambiguously
and then you're saying well i don't know
what it means
i understand what mathematics would mean
if mathematics was fundamental for me
please help clarify for me what the heck
does that mean because to me that's just
equally i can understand the statement
that mathematics describes what we've
seen so far but then to say that
mathematics is what we've seen so far i
don't understand what that is is what is
the mathematics and then when we say
it's a rule what is a rule we can play
that game so can you help me understand
the ontology
um
this is the
so first of all assuming that we're not
worrying here about things like girls in
completeness here more the other things
about math eating its own tail sure um
um we're not trying to do for example
press pressburger arithmetic which would
allow you to suit to avoid
girdles and complete stream or anything
um
it's
that's one of the things that i find so
a deep
flaw or attribute to me
is that
the more i can be
[Music]
smashed on my ass
by the universe
realizing that i have been misconstruing
my limitations
for being those of the
universe the more i feel i'm making
progress the more i actually that's my
aesthetic
acme
i don't think i can answer your question
and that to me
and i understand your question and feel
your question
and the fact that i cannot answer to me
is a
[Music]
beautiful stunning illustration of the
fact that the deficiency is in me
it's a feature not a bug
it's a feature not a bug
yup um things like um
i don't know how much you know about
algorithmic information complexities
from no i have a question about that i
would like to get to that later
someone i would like information
complexity
i view it as the most
the only true philosophy metaphysics
and by far the deepest that we've ever
come across
girdle
was
his result was one of the most important
philosophical results
precisely because
to my thinking aesthetically
because it was a
incontrovertible demonstration of how
all that we were so sure
we all thought the same as david hilbert
did
and we were wrong
and whether we can understand it or not
is irrelevant
and this is a similar kind of a thing i
do
feel that question you're asking and the
fact that i don't understand what it
means to give it as an answer
doesn't mean that that conclusion
which is causing that
question of yours that the conclusion is
wrong it's a limitation in me
that i can't grapple with what the
conclusion even means
just like hilbert couldn't grapple with
what girdle meant
okay speaking of limitations i know you
said that you have you have to you're
keeping an eye on the clock so how about
i give an outline of what we have left
to talk about and we can
determine how we're going to parse our
time to most efficiently get through
these
okay
okay so and i have like we're not even
third way done so that we'll have to
pick and choose some of these um or
would it make sense to have a follow-up
we can definitely have a follow-up yeah
given the time how about we then do
i'm not sure how you want to do the
video splicing
on your end we'll just wear the same
clothing and pretend it's all one
session yeah we could do that so far
much much of my clothing this time of
year tends to be um
yeah um
but uh yeah but if we could then just
schedule another time yeah and convene
okay so i'm assuming you have to go in
about 10 minutes is that correct yup
okay so let me at least go through the
questions and then we don't have to
answer them but let me just outline
lap classes demon i wanted to know
about how your inference limits on
inferences limits on inference devices
what that has to say about the places do
you mean but outline that for the
audience and then joseph rakoveca
apparently has a substantially
simplified argument involving turing
machines and free will which like we
just talked about free will i haven't
looked at his and i want to know if you
could comment like what was his argument
how is it simpler i don't i don't know
that particular one let's forget about
that then cross-validation how can
cross-validation be used to exploit the
scientific method i think that one we
should definitely do before you leave
then we've got to get to the definition
of observers we can save that for later
because that's quite a lengthy
conversation and then i wanted to talk
about
of complexity
and
you mentioned
that there are different bounds which
was extremely interesting on kamagarov
isn't bounded and that's intuitively
obvious why it's not bounded but then
thermodynamic complexity is bounded well
i don't know what thermodynamic
complexity is and i wanted you to
explain to me in the audience
what it is
and then i also wanted to know if you
know about assembly theory have you
heard about assembly theory
um you mean the stuff of annoyments no
no
it's recent it's by lee cronin who's a
chemist oh oh lee's stuff yeah oh yeah
lee is quite
he is quite a character um
yeah yeah okay so he's not calling it
assembly theory is he okay logical
irreversibility versus thermodynamic
irreversibility what's the difference
between those
then i also wanted to know if
the way that you can quantify an
observer which is extremely interesting
is that related to a notion of
intelligence so we could talk about that
later you also mentioned the most
profound results in philosophy come out
of algorithmic information theory and
that's where my question for you was
what the heck is algorithmic information
theory can you give some examples why do
you say that it's the most profound and
then we have several audience questions
so we have edward lee of berkeley
professor kevin knuth has a question for
you
hmm okay he has quite a few he and he
also said to say hi to you
okay i say hi back
anil seth has a question for you carl
fristen i'm sure you've heard of carl
fursten that was a question neil i know
as well yeah so there's so much we got
to get to and i know that your time is
extremely valuable and i appreciate that
you spent
as much time with me already and that
you're even offering to spend some more
time with me what a blessing man thank
you
well
um
let me put it this way um
[Music]
this is some of the most
near and dear to my heart would be a
glib thing i view these as like the most
profound things that
any human minds can be engaging with
and
[Music]
i am sure that just as in so many other
things i'm just full of
fecal matter shall we say
about tons of things and if i don't
you're helping
to have these kinds of
considerations and
cognitive wrestlings
um
conveyed out to a broader set of people
who can
join this
mosh pit of wrestling with these things
the more the better
more power to you independent me let me
fall under a bus tomorrow but these are
the little let me know but whatever yeah
these issues i think yeah
they should be engaged with and i think
that's
you know i am that's
something i do passionately agree with
and i thank you you
very very much for helping to um have
them be engaged with an embroider
well thank you for providing me some
material to engage with okay now with
regard to cross-validation and
exploiting the scientific method why
don't we get to that quickly and then
we'll wrap up for today okay so you said
that in one of your talks we can use
cross-validation to exploit the
scientific method first what is
cross-validation you have to explain
that to the audience and then how does
it undermine science yeah um it's
actually i'm not sure what the exact
quote was but basically cross-validation
is the scientific method formalized
so
one aspect of the form of the scientific
method like so many um glib phrases it's
good and it leaves a lot out um
the scientific method we
don't we put far more
[Music]
um posterior probability we assign far
more credence
in a theory
if it predicts phenomena that we have
not already observed and then are found
to be true
so you know famously for example the um
uh
who was it was eddington and um einstein
the observation of during the eclipse
and so on so forth
um
so another way to say that is that if i
give you two theories a and b
and i asked both of them to make a
prediction about something that neither
of them hasn't yet seen
um an a predicts it accurately and b
does not then we say let's go with a on
making any subsequent predictions
i'm going over and above
and so that it can be viewed as part of
the scientific method
um now let's see what that might mean in
the context of machine learning
well if i want to choose among a bunch
of machine learning algorithms
one way to do it is to
give them all a bunch of data
and hold out some data
let them train on the data they have and
then just see which one does best on the
data it doesn't have
and this is actually done in contests
bake offs they're sometimes called all
the time
you know we're going to choose between
the following character recognition
algorithms by giving them all of this
data set holding out some other examples
and then seeing who does best
um
you can also though do that yourself
so to speak by say i've got myself i've
got a bunch of different algorithms that
i can use i've got a fixed data set
let me
play like i'm holding a bake off
train all these algorithms a part of my
data set
on part of my data is it see which one
does best on my held out data
take that one now train on everything
and use it to make my subsequent
predictions and use that as to choose
among different algorithms
just me myself as a solo machine learner
or to set parameters of a single
algorithm
that what i've just described to you is
what's called cross-validation
it is it is part and parcel of machine
learning algorithms it is part and
parcel of the scientific method
it does not get around the no free lunch
theorems
that in point of fact
you can actually show and this is some
really strange stuff that will that i
would be very happy to talk about but it
will require some care in the discussion
that
the
algorithm of
of anti-cross validation
of choosing the scientific theory that
does worst at predicting
there are just as many priors
for which that is going to outperform
the scientific method as the other way
around
so very strange it almost makes no sense
when i just say it that way so what
would be an example of a statement that
we believe is scientifically true but
you believe it was founded by
inadvertently exploiting something
everything in science
whenever i cross the street everything
this is what i meant by why the the
norfolk lunch theorem is sometimes
just my notes to myself tp
everything
um the anti-reasoning by no free lunch
anti-reasoning rather than reasoning
in terms of
inductive reasoning let me state what
cross-validation is one more time simply
to the audience so that some of the
people who weren't able to follow can
follow cross-validation if you've heard
on a previous podcast i believe i talked
about kripkenstein there's a
rule-following paradox so it's similar
to this imagine you have a kid a child
you're teaching how do you add digits so
you have a set of a thousand cards and
each of them is an arithmetical an
arithmetic statement a statement about
arithmetic so two plus five is seven
three to the power of 4 is is
81 and then you show the child the set
of statements that are correct and you
show them the set of statements that are
incorrect so some of these are true plus
5 equals minus 1.
and then you say
and then you want to find out is the
child following a rule but the child
could have simply if you give them the
whole deck the child could simply
memorize all of these cards and you can
show them a card two plus three equals
five and you can say is this correct and
they'll be like that's correct and then
you don't know are they following the
rules of arithmetic or have they simply
fit the data so one way you can get
around that is you take let's say 70 of
your cards and you say learn some rule
child i'm not even going to tell you
what the rule is that's the point i want
you to learn figure out how to add by
looking at these examples and i'm saving
30 of these here so i can show you new
cards and say
is this one correct or incorrect and
then judging by that i can say whether
or not you're following the rules
correctly okay so that's what
cross-validation is now how does that
undermine science so that's essentially
the scientific enterprises you've
outlined it and how
so how does the no free lunch theorem
relate to that say it one more time
please
um
[Music]
it sounds like what you're saying is
well i could come up like the child can
come up with any rule and it would still
be
i could still find some situations in
which that rule is valid
just as many and in fact you could have
whatever the child says you could i
could define a new algorithm
which is take whatever the child says
and go with the opposite so to speak
and there are going to be as many priors
as many universes
for talking about the scientific method
in which that anti algorithm
is actually going to
end up doing best on yet unseen
situations
rather than the original one
and it's
becomes very very
pointed when
it's things like um
[Music]
it means that for example there are
going to be as many situations in which
your algorithm does worse than random
guessing as in which it does better
no matter what your algorithm is
now this implies to me that scientific
methods should not work yet it seems to
so why the problem yep the problem tp
because your very statement it seems to
is based upon the data set that has
worked so far
but then when we go to off drink the no
free lunch says doesn't mean the fact
that it's worked so far well in the past
has anything to say about how we'll work
in the future
it's just like evolution has worked so
well in the past has no implications
about how well it will work in the
future
so
it eats its own tail
the fact that anything that that we have
used go up to a meta level a meta
algorithm of some sort
where i'm choosing between strategies
for choosing between strategies doesn't
matter
um in fact there's a um philosopher
karl schers
who um just came out with a book on meta
induction it's making a big
um splash or waves you know whatever the
um serious aquatic metaphor of choice
and um he's got a whole chapter on no
free lunch and i actually just wrote a
commentary
um on that there were some that were
solicited and it's going to be appearing
in
the journal of general philosophy of
science or something like that i forget
the precise name
where he claims that his results um get
around no free lunch but no they don't
he's talking about meta induction at
this level so you're doing induction
about induction about induction
to try to essentially um break the
guardian
you know break free your binders
but they don't break free the binders
you're still stuck and we have no reason
to believe the scientific method
but i sure as hell believe it listen to
the earlier part of this podcast when i
was
going whole hog i was the most died in
the wool
um conservative dogmatic scientific
reasoner you could come up with
and then the next breath i'll tell you
that it's got no legitimacy
by the way would you consider math to be
scientific or do you consider science to
be separate from math
oh um this is like you asked me before
about being an artist versus and so and
so forth um i don't um
i don't make those kinds of distinctions
i
yeah the reason i was asking is if you
did
consider it then it would be as if what
you're saying is by using science i
undermine science
that is by using that which is subset of
which which is subset of science girdle
by using math undermined math
yup
well girdle undermined a part of math
whereas you're undermining the entire
scientific enterprise
yep pushing it further pushing it
further and then things like the
inference devices work
go even further they um in some senses
undermine the notion of
epistemology full stop
of even knowing something no matter how
that information is arrived at even by
luck
and this gets to another very very much
tongue-in-cheek definition of free will
which was very very much tongue-in-cheek
um
and then the stuff on noisy deductive
reasoning would say that oh but if math
itself including that reasoning that
you're using to come to these other
theorems is itself a noisy process
inherently
it's it's not it's not turtles all the
way down it's some uh straw men all the
way down or something like that
paper tigers all the way down
well you got to get going and so for the
people who are watching if you have any
questions for david he'll be coming back
on
the theories of everything podcast at
some point so leave your questions below
we'll be talking about the same well
forget about that i can add i can change
that later
professor thank you so much
well thanks this is a lot of fun um
all right we'll do well thanks very very
much um
yeah well thank you interesting and the
more actually
from my sitting in my chair the more i
actually feel that you
kurt are engaging in actually
revealing what it is that you're
actually thinking that makes
it makes it more interesting more what
more
more interesting um but also more
stimulating
more alive um it means that i can now um
extract
insights from you as well as the other
way around
grounds for thought and that's something
i always value
great
okay man we'll talk we have much to talk
about
take care all right you as well bye
again recall that this was part one of a
two-part conversation in the second part
we take audience questions as well as
hearing from kevin knuth and nell seth
carl fristen and chris langan who all
have questions posed to the great david
walpart
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full-time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you